World peace in record time
Sure that'll last
My name is Stephen Strange,
and I've been looking for you for a long time.
Welcome back everyone, It's Charlie
This will be my full Marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 6 video
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references
so we'll break it all down
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We finally started getting a bunch of post-credits
scenes in all the episodes of them putting together
this multiverse theme.
So it sounds like they are like ramping things up
as we get to the last couple of episodes.
easier because we are getting closer to the finale
a lot of people have been asking will there be a
what if season 3
Yes they're already working on it right now.
I don't know when it's going to air it.
Probably like 20, 25, maybe 2026,
depending on how far along they are.
bit careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll start at the beginning. Work
our way through shop by.
I talked about Easter Eggs, WTF moments
and that Post-Credits scene is sort of like
the end credits with Supreme Strange showing up
but starting with the episode title.
What If Kahhori Reshaped the World?
I'm probably going to mispronounce her name
just a little bit because they tried to be
as authentic as possible to real world
Mohawk, Native American history.
they even included a special
thanks to the Mohawk Nation in the end credits scene
because they collaborated with them on the episode
to make sure that the history
was accurate for these people, Like these are
what they were like during this part of history,
and this is the way those characters would react
if they went through these similar circumstances.
like of a bunch of the Mohawk
suddenly gained a bunch of superpowers.
This is how most of them would react to it.
And this is what would happen as a result,
They also wrote a lot of brand new music
and theme songs for the episode.
And I think they collaborated with them on that too,
based on a lot of classic Mohawk traditions.
The episode is basically
what if the Tesseract had given powers
to the Native American Mohawks
before the colonization of America?
How would that have changed
the balance of power in the world?
So it's kind of like Wakanda in the Black Panther
character in how the Wakanda nation evolved
because they were so powerful
the real big change in this episode, they're like
they go in a completely different direction.
instead of closing the borders of America
or trying to take over the planet, Kahhori
and her tribe are very active
in trying to bring peace to the rest of the world,
even though at the end of the episode Supreme
Strange is like, Yeah, we'll see how long that lasts.
there's just this own very dark sense of humor.
you have to remember how hard core
his origin story was like.
He destroyed his entire universe.
debris. Jacobs is voicing the character.
She's also playing a completely different character
during the Echo episodes,
But it's not meant to be connected to her.
What if character is just a coincidence?
she's a totally new character that they created
just for this episode or for the show just in general.
I'm assuming they might bring her back in season three.
They brought Captain Carter back.
Like there's always a couple really big characters
that they treat with really big importance
that they want to keep bringing back.
sometimes these characters
work their way into live action, so it is possible
we see Kahhori in live action at some point,
maybe during Secret Wars.
Sometimes.
Characters that originate on the shows
and in the movies also work their way into the comics.
Kind of like flowing in reverse.
Harley Quinn over at DC
is probably one of the most famous examples of that.
like she started on Batman the Animated series
and then worked her way
into DC Comics and became a big comic book character.
Q And he was playing her younger brother, WADA.
She's actually also playing the live action
version of Katara during Avatar,
The Last Airbender Netflix episodes.
I literally just did a big trailer video for that.
So I'll link up along the description,
but you have all the bending in that universe,
in the Avatar universe,
their kind of energy bending in this episode.
Different kind of energy bending
like they're not bending their own spiritual energy.
They're bending more literal energy.
if you don't know what energy bending is
or you've never seen Avatar, The Last Airbender.
Don't worry, there's a lot of really cool stuff
coming early next year
and we have a bunch of animated avatar stuff
coming soon to.
one of the reasons why they cast her, obviously,
is because she's a good actress,
but she's also of Mohawk Native American descent.
Just like all the characters in the episode.
So they try to be as authentic
to the Mohawk as possible.
one of the other major differences in the episode,
as you could tell immediately almost, is
the first episode that what if has ever done.
That's almost entirely in foreign language.
Mohawk in Spanish.
The Watcher in Supreme Strange are the only ones
in the episode who actually speak in English.
during the Marvel Studios intro,
they played the Speedrun version again, but they wrote
special theme music, like I said, for the episode,
and gave the character a bunch of her own theme music,
which plays over these titles, they'll probably release
a vinyl album or put it on digital at some point.
So you will be able to get the soundtrack pretty soon,
The Watcher narrates
how history went differently in this universe.
Ragnarok comes to Asgard much earlier in the timeline
certain is able to destroy Asgard R.I.P.
killing Odin damaging the tesseract in the process
which he tried to use against solder.
It's Clancy Brown
who came back to do the voice for Solder again.
He did his voice during Thor Ragnarok.
the dialog they gave him in
the episode is also similar to the dialog
that he had during Thor Ragnarok
when he was destroying Asgard during that movie.
then the damaged tesseract winds up falling to earth
in the infinity stone energy from the space stone
because we're talking about an infinity stone here
creates a portal into a pocket dimension
inside the space stone itself.
And because it's a space stone, we're talking about
opening portals, moving stuff through space.
when people come into proximity with the broken
tesseract, they're pulled into that other dimension.
and because inside that pocket dimension, all
the organic life is laced with infinity stone energy.
The minute you come into contact with it,
like you drink the water or you eat the food,
or you eat the plant life
You also gain those powers to.
they all have the same basic power,
superspeed, telekinesis.
Their bodies are way stronger.
Maybe not Hulk strong,
but much stronger than a normal human.
Like they can run through the ships
and they have the ability to open portals,
but it seems like some of them are a little bit
more powerful than others.
but I also think in the episode, Courtney,
for instance, tries
a little bit harder to unlock her powers more fully.
So I think the idea is that
they can all train their powers up to be even greater.
Captain Marvel also wound up
coming into contact with Tesseract Energy,
getting her powers, Infinity Stone powers, basically.
But they're completely different
from all of these characters.
Powers they show you where most of the episode
takes place in the Americas.
This is where the Mohawk lived
during that part of history.
we meet Kori and her tribal.
They're picking corn,
just going about their regular day.
This is meant to be as accurate as possible to
what their life was like during this period in history.
Like the way that they lived, the houses they lived in
what their villages look like in this universe.
Because of the way the tesseract fell to earth,
they explained that her tribe had a war a long time ago
with other neighboring tribes around the site
where the broken tesseract crash,
because they sensed a great power in this, quote,
forbidden lake during that ancient battle
because it created a portal that sucked a bunch
of people from all the different tribes into it.
Everyone at the time thought that it was cursed
and just caused them to lay down arms and make a peace
agreement, cursing the area and forbidding
anyone from ever going to the battle site.
So no one ever really learned the truth
about the Tesseract portal until now.
the sky world
she references became part of their folklore.
After that great battle, the legends that they passed
down to the younger generations.
but in the episode because of the Tesseract portal,
it winds up being an actual place,
just an alternate dimension
that everybody gets transported to Her speech
about how the power of the lake
should have brought the tribes together instead of
causing a war between them is foreshadowing
for the way they end the episode.
When she makes peace with the rest of the world,
starting with the Spanish
basically flipping the script on the history
of what condyle like instead of closing their borders
up, like closing up shop and just kicking everyone out
and leaving them to their own devices,
they actually try to bring peace to the entire world
without conquering it.
you kind of see how this plays out
in present day in the MCU,
like there's a war brewing around Wakanda
in all their vibranium.
They kind of got into that during Black Panther,
Wakanda forever.
Like, give us all of your vibranium, Val,
the United States president,
all the other nations
all want that sweet, sweet vibranium honey.
they'll probably pay that off during Captain America
four Brave New World
then we see the Spanish conquistadors
attack their village.
They're looking for the fountain of youth,
which is based on real life history.
So Ponce de
Leon was a Spanish explorer who discovered Florida
in the early 1500s
when he was actually looking for the fountain of youth.
Generally, the episode is meant to take place
around this period in real world history.
they run from them and fall into the cave
containing the broken tesseract in the portal.
Kahhori winds up falling into it and into the alternate
dimension the way they show her origin here, too.
It's also similar to Scarlet Witch's origin
with the Mind stone during one division,
the way it unlocked the power in her it's
also giving a lot of Lord of the Rings
energy with Bilbo
finding the ring of power in that deep, dark cave.
the space stone pocket dimension is also
a bit of an Easter egg for the soul world of the soul.
Stone In the comics, soul gem in the comics
contains a pocket dimension called the soul world.
It's not a paradise like this place, though.
already explained all the logic of the pocket dimension
here.
Like all the organic life is laced
with infinity stone energy.
So the minute you come into contact with that,
like you drink the water, you eat the food,
the plant life, the animals, you gain those powers to.
So like even the fish that they pull out of the water
here, the fish are also laced
with infinity stone energy, superpowered fish
that they're eating basically.
they also don't really explain this,
but it seems like there's a time dilation
effect inside here where time passes slower
because a bunch of time seems like it goes
by where she does her big powers montage,
just training her abilities up before she goes back.
But when she goes back,
it seems like no time has passed at all.
she once waking up. They give her new clothes.
Everything here is designed
based on tesseract energy like this.
Blue designs baked into their natural Mohawk designs
Attracts gives her a tutorial on
how the pocket dimension works
and she vows to save her people
returning to stop the Spanish
and they give her the training montage.
It's a bit like Rambo Pocahontas
with her own theme music.
The soundtrack for the episode
was actually pretty cool.
So hopefully they do release this pretty soon.
They explained that all her other Mohawk ancestors
who are living here with superpowers view it as a gift,
like it's a paradise, that they're all just enjoying
sort of like a permanent vacation.
They don't really care about any of the things
that they cared about before, even though they do
acknowledge that terrible things are happening
with their descendants.
to be fair.
They do say that a bunch of them have tried to escape
through the portal, but no one's actually
tried to pull the portal down closer to earth
the way that Kahhori does during the episode.
she winds up being the one to do that, inspiring
everyone else with a big rousing call to action.
Like we need to use our powers to help everyone else.
when they get into the argument where she tells them
that they need to use their powers to help everyone.
It kind of reminded me the classic Spider-Man panel
that everybody always posts doing the same thing
with Sauron in him not caring like, Nope, I don't want
to use my powers or my intellect to help the world.
I want to use them to turn people into dinosaurs.
her montage of her falling over and over again
reminded me of Loki falling.
she's been falling for 30 minutes.
They do their version of a great buffalo hunt
chasing their herd
to obtain the special tesseract fruit
that grows in their bodies.
She unlocks her powers even more.
And when he says, Welcome to the New World,
that's a bit of a reverse on the Spanish conquistadors
coming to America.
To them, America was the new world
the other conquistadors
get sucked into the portal
attacking the superpowered mohawk tribe.
These are kind of like those funny videos that you see
people posting online of dudes trying to rob people,
but the people they rob wind up being hardcore
M.A stars
just beating the crap out of them
when she stops all the bullets and takes their guns.
That's also
just like Magneto in that first X-Men movie.
there are a lot of X-Men vibes
just in general throughout the entire episode.
But they're not mutants technically.
the only reason why I say they're not mutants
is because you have to be born with the x
gene to be a traditional mutant like you, to be born
with your powers instead of getting them later in life
when you fall into a vat of toxic waste
or have some industrial accident
like classic Marvel characters, you're called a mutate
like Monica Rambeau, Spider-Man the Hulk.
They're all mutates, not mutants.
She unlocks her powers enough
to pull the portal to Earth, giving her a rousing call
to action before coming back alone
to stop the Spanish from taking her tribe.
this scene of her on the beach trying to stop them.
Then stop.
The cannon fire was also just like Magneto during X-Men
First Class, stopping all the missiles on the beach.
really cool
reveal to the rally moment
when all the Mohawks eyes appear in the forest,
showing that they've come through the portal
like they listened to her and they've come to help
after they destroy the ships and save everyone.
They explained that they went around
the rest of the country destroying all the Spanish
expeditionary forces
who had sent multiple separate groups across the coast.
So it imagine all these Mohawk running around America
at superspeed, destroying ships.
there's a bit of a time jump
and they pick up in the Spanish court with Queen
Isabella just yelling about while their ships
have been lost in quarry portals in their Mohawk team
making peace with her instead of destroying them,
which they could have done pretty easily,
like there'll be no future for your people
if you do not make peace And if you missed it.
When she's challenging the Queen of Spain, she's
speaking in Spanish, not in Mohawk.
That's why the queen could understand her,
because the queen cannot speak Mohawk
just as they make their peace offering.
And it seems like it's going to be successful.
Supreme,
strange opens his own portal from another universe,
claiming he's been looking for her for a long time now.
Maybe not hers specifically.
Probably just looking for someone like her
with a desire to help the entire planet.
Like this good natured person who has incredible powers
like you will be useful in the war to come
and basically it's like a repeat version of what
we just saw in the episode five Post-Credits scene
with Scarlet Witch doing the same thing
with Captain Carter pulling her across the multiverse.
when he was pulling in.
They also started playing some of his doctor
strange theme music.
He's basically putting together
his own version of a multiverse team.
Now, I don't know if they're going to be in opposition
to the multiverse team
the Scarlet Witch is putting together,
or if it's part of the same team
and they're just bringing them together on their own.
But either way, this is just reminding you
the supreme strange is back this season and I think
this is all set up for the last two episodes,
like the Marvel 1602 episode and then the finale.
because there's only one more episode
before the Marvel 1602 episode,
we'll probably get another Post-Credits
scene like this in episode seven.
we get the quick outro narration from the watcher.
Basically just narrating what we just saw go down.
And during the end credits,
like I said, there is a special
thanks to the Mohawk Nation
for collaborating on the episode
to help them with a lot of the law in the mythology
here, expanding on it
there are a bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode, so if you spotted any
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
There's not a lot that I know about actual real world
Mohawk history,
so there are probably a lot of Easter Eggs
that are specific to that mythology.
So if you do know a lot about that, you probably
spotted a bunch of things that other people missed.
big reminder. My episode
7 video will post tomorrow
That'll be the what if Hella found the Ten Rings episode
is basically the Shang Chi characters vs Odin
It looks like it's going to be another banger.
everybody click here for that video update the link
as soon as I post that, and click here for all my other
what if episodes
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!